When Rosie was a kid, they had a dog named Fu, a Shih Tzu. And Rosie's mom swears that she knows the exact day the dog went bad. It came when she heard about a discount way to get a dog grooming. It was this grooming school.
罗茜小时候养过一只叫“福”的狗，是一只西施犬。罗茜的妈妈发誓，她清楚地记得那只狗变坏的确切日子。那天她听说有一种打折的宠物美容服务，就是那家美容学校。
Her friend said that it didn't cost much, and they were very good. But my mother believes that this experience sort of ruined Fu. That somehow they tortured him and did something wrong in his first grooming.
她的朋友说费用不高，而且他们做得很好。但我母亲认为那次经历毁了“福”。不知怎的，他们在第一次美容时虐待了它，或者做了什么错事。
What? He went to get his hair cut, basically, and they ruined him as a dog?
什么？它只不过是去剪个毛，结果他们毁了一只狗？
Well, he got like shaved. And he got like full-on, summer shave. And he came back a different dog, according to my mother.
嗯，它被剃了毛。就像那种彻底的、夏日款式的剃毛。据我母亲说，它回来时已经变成另一只狗了。
After the grooming, he became a biter. Rosie got bit. Other people got bit. There were trips to the hospital, lots of drama. Fu hated people. And then the parrot arrived, Judy the parrot.
美容之后，它开始咬人。罗茜被咬了。其他人也被咬了。经常要去医院，闹剧不断。“福”讨厌人类。然后鹦鹉来了，朱迪，那只鹦鹉。
The neighbors had actually bought this parrot without understanding what a lot of trouble that parrots can be. Parrots can be very anxious birds, especially when you leave them alone. They can pull out their feathers. They can screech like a smoke alarm.
邻居们买这只鹦鹉时根本没意识到鹦鹉会带来多大的麻烦。鹦鹉是非常焦虑的鸟，尤其是当你把它们单独留下时。它们会拔掉自己的羽毛。它们会像火灾报警器一样尖叫。
So they took the bird cage and put a note on it that said, take this bird or we're going to cook it, and left the cage in front of our door. We were like two doors down the hall. So we took her in. And we didn't know-- we'd had dogs and cats, but we'd never had a bird. And before you knew it, we all loved her. You know, my mother she'd let the bird perch on the edge of her coffee cup in the morning and drink her morning coffee with her.
于是他们把鸟笼放在我们门口，上面贴了张纸条写着：“要么带走这只鸟，要么我们就要把它炖了”。我们就住在走廊尽头的两户人家，所以我们收留了它。我们不知道——我们养过猫狗，但从未养过鸟。没过多久，我们都爱上了它。你知道，我母亲早上会让鸟儿停在她咖啡杯的边缘，陪她一起喝早咖啡。
And Fu and Judy just quickly became best friends. I don't know what it was, but they just connected. And it was very cute, because you'd see this little, matted Shih Tzu and this like eight inch high parrot pacing the floor of the apartment together like they were walking down the hall having a chat.
“福”和朱迪很快就成了最好的朋友。我不知道是什么原因，但它们就是产生了共鸣。那场面非常可爱，因为你会看到这只毛发打结的小西施犬和这只八英寸高的鹦鹉一起在公寓的地板上踱步，就像它们在走廊里聊天散步一样。
Dog and parrot kind of strolling.
狗和鹦鹉在悠闲地散步。
They would stroll together. And Fu would roll on his back. He hated it when any person came near his stomach. She could crawl all over him. And she did. She would crawl up his chest, up to his face, peck at his face like she was giving him kisses.
它们会一起散步。“福”还会翻身露出肚皮。它讨厌任何人靠近它的肚子。但朱迪可以在它身上爬来爬去。它确实也这么做了。它会爬上它的胸口，爬到它的脸上，啄它的脸，就像在亲吻它一样。
This dog that would actually try to bite all of you?
这只曾经试图咬你们所有人的狗？
Yes, he loved it, loved the parrot. I mean, he'd had dog girlfriends before, and he got along fine with the cats. But we'd never seen him develop a friendship like that.
是的，它很喜欢，很爱这只鹦鹉。我是说，它以前也有过狗女友，和猫相处得也很好。但我们从未见过它建立过那样的友谊。
Oh, this is like the big--
噢，这就是那伟大的——
This was the big friendship, big romance.
这就是那段伟大的友谊，伟大的浪漫。
Of his life?
它一生的？
I think so.
我想是吧。
So this went on for a long, long time. And then, one day, Fu came into the kitchen to eat, and the whole family was there including the parrot, Judy.
这种情况持续了很长很长一段时间。然后有一天，“福”走进厨房准备吃东西，全家人都在那里，包括鹦鹉朱迪。
And she flew down to the floor and went over to Fu's bowls and, as I remember it, drank a little bit of his water. But then, she went into his food dish. And I don't know how that hadn't happened before. She took some bit of dog food into her beak, and, in just like a split second, he went over and bit the top-feathers right out of her head.
它飞到地板上，走到“福”的碗边，我记得它喝了一点水。但随后，它伸进它的食盆。我不知道之前怎么没发生过这种情况。它用喙叼走了一些狗粮，就在那一瞬间，它跑过去，把她头顶上的毛给咬秃了。
And she squawked, and squawked, and squawked. And sort of hyperventilated in this very alarming bird way, because they're so tiny, and you can hear them panting, and it sounds like they're going to just die from anxiety.
她尖叫着，尖叫着，尖叫着。以一种非常令人不安的鸟类方式急促呼吸，因为它们太小了，你能听到它们喘气，听起来好像它们就要因为焦虑而死了一样。
It's interesting how the traumatic event in his life was a bad haircut, and then he, basically, turns around and gives that to her.
有趣的是，它生命中的创伤性事件是一次糟糕的理发，然后它转头就把同样的遭遇给了她。
Yeah, but the bird was just ready to pass-out, she was so terrified. But after that, she pretty much stayed in my room with the door closed. Fu would come to the bedroom door and scratch, and scratch, and cry, and cry. And it was just awful. And she would usually squawk, not in a friendly, hey buddy, I miss you way, but in a fearful way. It was his best friend, and he'd just sit there at the door sort of scratching and pining. And that was that, really.
是啊，但这只鸟当时快晕过去了，它太害怕了。在那之后，它基本就待在我的房间里，关着门。“福”会来到卧室门口抓门，不停地抓、不停地哭。真的太可怕了。它通常会发出尖叫，不是那种友好的、“嘿伙计，我想你”的叫声，而是一种恐惧的叫声。那是它最好的朋友，而它就坐在门边，抓着门，渴望着。事情就是这样，真的。
So he drove his best friend away.
所以它赶走了它最好的朋友。
Because he just snapped. In one moment he was like a dog more than he was a parrot's pal.
因为它突然失控了。在那一刻，它更多是一只狗，而不是鹦鹉的朋友。
It was like suddenly he turned into a real dog, and then it's like she realized, oh, he's a dog. My friend is a dog. And then she became a parrot again.
就像它突然变成了一只真正的狗，而它意识到，哦，它是一只狗。我的朋友是一只狗。然后她又变回了一只鹦鹉。
I don't know if she realized he was a dog, and she was a bird. Whatever their essential animal nature's, what we knew was that they had been best friends. And in some ridiculous, anthropomorphic way, it looked very romantic. And then it was totally betrayed.
我不知道她是否意识到它是狗，她是鸟。无论它们基本的动物本性如何，我们所知道的是它们曾是最好的朋友。以某种荒谬的、拟人化的方式来看，这显得非常浪漫。然后却被彻底背叛了。
When he snapped at her.
当它对她发火时。
When he snapped at her. And then it was over. I think it was just betrayal.
当它对她发火时。然后一切就结束了。我认为这仅仅是背叛。
I know, but he made one, little mistake. I don't know why, but I'm identifying with the dog here, very strongly.
我知道，但它犯了一个小错误。我不知道为什么，但我现在非常强烈地认同这只狗。
Well, we did too. We did too. It was horrible to hear him pining at the bedroom door. I mean, it really was like this awful, tragic romance. And he pined, and pined, and pined.
嗯，我们也一样。我们也一样。听着它在卧室门口渴望的样子太可怕了。我是说，这真的就像一段糟糕、悲惨的恋情。它渴望着，渴望着，一直渴望着。
He pined for her, Rosie says, until the day he died. Judy never forgave him. We talked to anybody who knows about parrots, they'll tell you that people are constantly misunderstanding them and underestimating them. I was talking to this guy for this week's show who did research with parrots at MIT. And he was explaining to me how they're amazingly smart. For instance, he says that it's actually a myth that they only mimic words. They actually learn the words. They use them correctly. But it's one thing for people to misunderstand parrots, until I heard about Fu and Judy, I had no idea that other animals might make the same mistake. If only Fu knew how to treat a parrot.
罗茜说，它一直渴望着她，直到死的那天。“朱迪”从未原谅它。我们和任何了解鹦鹉的人交谈，他们都会告诉你，人们总是误解和低估它们。我为本周的节目采访了一位在麻省理工学院研究鹦鹉的家伙。他向我解释了它们是多么聪明。例如，他说它们只会模仿词汇其实是个误区。它们实际上是在学习这些词。它们能正确地使用它们。但人们误解鹦鹉是一回事，在听说“福”和朱迪的故事之前，我不知道其他动物也会犯同样的错误。要是“福”知道该怎么对待鹦鹉就好了。
But today on our show, we have stories of people underestimating what certain animals are like. Not just parrots, no, no, no, how narrow would that be. How small minded, how limited the vision and scope. No, no, we will not just confine ourselves to parrots this hour. We will also be talking about pot-bellied pigs. It's the Parrot and the Pot-bellied Pig. By the end of this hour, people get thrown in jail, relationships end, love affairs start, all because of these two animals.
但在今天的节目中，我们要讲一些人们低估动物的故事。不只是鹦鹉，不，不，不，那太狭隘了。太鼠目寸光，视野和范围太局限了。不，不，这一小时我们不会局限于鹦鹉。我们还要谈谈大肚猪。这就是“鹦鹉与大肚猪”。这一小时结束时，会有人入狱、关系破裂、恋情开始，所有的一切都是因为这两只动物。
For WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Act one of our show today, Parrot. Act two-- Pig. Act three- Combo Platter, in which David Sedaris has a story with both the parrot and the pot-bellied pig. Stay with us.
这里是WBEZ芝加哥电台的《这就是美国生活》，由公共广播国际公司分发。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天节目的第一幕，鹦鹉。第二幕——猪。第三幕——大杂烩，大卫·塞达里斯将讲述一个同时涉及鹦鹉和大肚猪的故事。请继续收听。
Act One, Parrot. Eric and Alex have been telling their parrot story since they were in school years ago. They've told this story many, many times to friends, to family, to strangers. In fact, the night before they came into the studio to tell this story, they went to a bar, and they practiced telling the story to random customers including, at one point, an actual movie star, who happen to be in town filming a big, blockbuster movie.
第一幕，鹦鹉。埃里克和亚历克斯自从多年前在学校起就一直讲述着他们的鹦鹉故事。他们已经把这个故事讲了非常非常多次，讲给朋友、家人、陌生人听。事实上，在他们走进录音室讲述这个故事的前一天晚上，他们去了一家酒吧，练习向随机的顾客讲这个故事，其中有一次，甚至包括一位碰巧在城里拍摄一部大制作电影的电影明星。
They've told the story so many times that at this point they're not exactly sure they even have the facts right. Which means something to them, because they are reporters. Facts are their business. And, in fact, this story began as an assignment in journalism school. Alex turned in the story for a class, but, even after he did that, the two of them continued to run down leads and interview people for the story. They could not stop themselves, such is their crush on this story. The story begins in Central Park in New York City at some party thrown by some big company.
他们把这个故事讲了太多次，以至于现在他们甚至不确定自己讲的事实是否准确。这让他们很在意，因为他们是记者。事实是他们的本职工作。事实上，这个故事最初是新闻学院的一个作业。亚历克斯为一门课交了这个故事，但在那之后，他们两人还是继续追寻线索并采访相关人员。他们无法停止，因为他们对这个故事太痴迷了。故事开始于纽约中央公园的一场大型公司聚会。
Somehow, a young wannabe actor, aspiring actor of Puerto Rican descent from Brooklyn, named Johnny de Villa winds up at this party.
不知怎的，一位来自布鲁克林的、波多黎各血统的年轻、渴望表演的演员，名叫约翰尼·德·维拉，闯进了这个聚会。
You mean, just like wanders in?
你是说，就像溜进去那样？
Yeah, maybe he's there with a girlfriend. I'm sure Eric recalls why he's there.
是的，也许他是和女朋友一起去的。我相信埃里克记得他为什么在那儿。
I have no recollection whatsoever. But I think sometime we say, he crashed the party. And sometimes we say that he-- in any case, he got there early, very early, and he stayed late, very late.
我完全没印象了。但我认为有时我们会说，他硬闯进来的。有时我们又说他——总之，他去得很早，非常早，走得很晚，非常晚。
And he drank.
而且他喝了酒。
And it may well be, as we recall it now, that he smoked a lot of pot.
照我们现在的回忆，很可能他抽了不少大麻。
Smoked a marijuana cigarette.
抽了一支大麻烟。
But it may not be.
但也许没有。
It may not be.
也许没有。
That's the way we tell it now.
这就是我们现在的说法。
That he's high?
他吸嗨了吗？
Yeah, but in any case he decides to wander out on his own at about 1:30 or 2:00 in the morning. And he wanders through the park for a little while. And he wanders through these gates that are open.
是的，但无论如何，他在凌晨1点半或2点左右决定独自溜出去。他在公园里游荡了一会儿。然后他穿过了那些敞开的大门。
Well, yeah. In this section of the story, we should say is his recollection, what he later told police. So he wanders in and, before he knows it, there's sort of a distant splashing and sea lions. And he's just sort of walking and thinking.
嗯，是的。这一部分故事应该说是他的回忆，是他后来告诉警察的。所以他走进去，还没回过神，就听到远处有水花声和海狮的声音。他只是走着，想着事情。
And he thinks that literally, they accidentally just left the gates open to the entire zoo. That's his story?
他真的认为他们不小心把整个动物园的大门都敞开了？这是他的故事？
And, of course, the zoo told us that that would be absolutely impossible.
当然，动物园告诉我们那绝对是不可能的。
Maybe there's some plausibility, but it's unlikely that they left the aviary open.
也许有一定的合理性，但他们不太可能把鸟舍留着没关。
Which is where Johnny found himself after a little bit of wandering. And the door is wide open. He strolls right in, and, the way he tells it, there was a long line of cages.
约翰尼溜达了一会儿后发现自己就在那儿。门大开着。他直接走了进去，据他所说，里面有一长排笼子。
There was a mist.
有一层雾。
A mist, he says.
一层雾，他说。
A mist indoors?
室内有雾？
Well, he may have been high.
嗯，他可能吸嗨了。
Or he may not have. He definitely said, there was this mist. And the mist sort of cleared. and before him was a parrot with brilliant green plumage and a red tuft on its head. And they locked eyes.
或者他可能没有。他确实说过，有一层雾。雾散开后，在他面前是一只鹦鹉，有着明亮的绿色羽毛和红色的头冠。他们对视了。
He looked at the parrot. The parrot looked at him. And they had an instant connection, he says.
他看着鹦鹉。鹦鹉看着他。他说，他们产生了瞬间的共鸣。
And so he says to the parrot, "you want to go?" And the parrot says to him, "yeah." And he says, "Let's go."
于是他对鹦鹉说：“你想走吗？”鹦鹉对他说：“想。”于是他说：“那我们走吧。”
The parrot says him, "yeah?"
鹦鹉对他说“想”？
As he recalls.
他是这么回忆的。
As he recalls. Which is unlikely, because this is not a talking parrot.
他是这么回忆的。这不太可能，因为这不是一只会说话的鹦鹉。
This is a crucial plot point, actually, that it's not a talking parrot. What it is though, is it's an extremely endangered parrot, which Johnny does not know. And the third, and most important thing that he doesn't know, is that this bird is suffering from an acute respiratory illness which necessitates that it take antibiotics. And the zoo has been treating it with these antibiotics for several days or weeks.
事实上，这是一个关键的情节转折，它不是一只会说话的鹦鹉。但它是一只极度濒危的鹦鹉，约翰尼对此一无所知。第三个、也是最重要的一点他不知道的是，这只鸟正患有一种严重的呼吸道疾病，需要服用抗生素。动物园已经用这些抗生素治疗了它好几天或几周了。
So it's endangered. It's valued at $20,000. And it's sick. And he walks out of the zoo with it on his shoulder and gets on the subway.
所以它是濒危物种。价值2万美元。而且它还生病了。他把它扛在肩上走出动物园，坐上了地铁。
And he takes this parrot all the way back to Bay Ridge, Brooklyn.
他把这只鹦鹉一直带回了布鲁克林的湾脊区。
But the parrot is not a domestic pet. It's a wild parrot. It's flying around.
但鹦鹉不是家养宠物。这是只野生鹦鹉。它在到处乱飞。
It's squawking. It's poorly behaved. So even though Johnny is a vegetarian and animal lover, he is starting to have a hard time dealing with this.
它在尖叫。它表现得很差。所以尽管约翰尼是个素食主义者和动物爱好者，他开始觉得处理这事很困难。
Buyer's remorse.
买家悔恨。
Yeah, buyer's remorse.
是的，买家悔恨。
Now you know, buyer's remorse is traditionally a phrase that is used for people who buy something.
你知道，“买家悔恨”传统上是用来形容买东西的人的短语。
Traditionally, yes.
传统上是这样，是的。
So Johnny reads up on birds, Alex and Eric say. Tries to figure out what to feed it. Tries to do right by the bird. But the bird is wreaking such havoc, flying around his apartment and screaming, that unsure what else to do, Johnny tries something that he has only heard of, he clips the parrot's wings. He clips them with scissors-- scissors. This rare, endangered species, a $20,000 bird.
所以亚历克斯和埃里克说，约翰尼查了关于鸟类的书。试着弄清楚喂它什么。试着善待这只鸟。但鸟儿造成了极大的混乱，在公寓里到处乱飞、尖叫，不知如何是好的约翰尼尝试了他只听说过的方法，他剪掉了鹦鹉的翅膀。他用剪刀剪掉了——剪刀。这稀有、濒危的物种，一只2万美元的鸟。
Owning a parrot has turned out to be very different than Johnny expected, which actually seems to be what always happens to people who own a parrot. And after a month, he wants to unload it on somebody else.
事实证明，养鹦鹉和约翰尼预想的非常不同，这似乎也是养鹦鹉的人总是会遇到的情况。一个月后，他想把它丢给别人。
He has a friend named Ed Jupp.
他有个朋友叫埃德·朱普。
Another actor. They've met on the set somewhere. In fact, Ed's been in some movies. He was in a Ron Howard movie called The Paper.
也是个演员。他们在某个片场认识的。事实上，埃德演过一些电影。他参演了罗恩·霍华德的一部电影，叫《媒体先锋》。
He was in Born on the 4th of July.
他演过《生于七月四日》。
He was in Born on the 4th of July. His full-time day-job or one of the ways he makes money, is that he puts together resumes for other actors. He's doing this for Johnny and expects to be paid about $500. The other thing is that it's hard for him to get this work done, because he has a girlfriend named Dawn.
他演过《生于七月四日》。他的全职工作，或者他赚钱的方式之一，是为其他演员整理简历。他在为约翰尼做这件事，预计能拿到大约500美元。还有件事是，他很难完成工作，因为他有一个叫道恩的女朋友。
By the way, Ed happens to be confined to a wheelchair. He's a paraplegic.
顺便说一下，埃德正好坐轮椅。他截瘫。
As is Dawn.
道恩也是。
And while Ed's trying to work, Dawn rolls in every day.
当埃德试图工作时，道恩每天都会滚进来。
--15 or 20 times a day during his working hours. He has sort of a home office. She rolls in looking for kisses and attention. And it also happens that, I think, she's always wanted a parrot.
——他工作时，她每天进来15或20次。他有个家庭办公室。她进来寻找亲吻和关注。而且碰巧，我想，她一直想要一只鹦鹉。
So when Johnny comes to Ed and says, well you know, I don't have $500, but I've got this parrot.
所以当约翰尼去找埃德说，你知道，我没有500美元，但我有这只鹦鹉。
For Ed, it's just like it's solving a bunch of problems at once.
对埃德来说，就像是同时解决了好多问题。
Ed finds this to be a marvelous opportunity.
埃德觉得这是一个绝佳的机会。
Now Ed and Dawn don't know, certainly, that its been stolen from the Central Park Zoo. And, most importantly, they too do not realize that this bird has been suffering, now for a month untreated with a serious respiratory infection. Not knowing this, they're chain smokers. And their apartment was--
当然，埃德和道恩不知道它被从中央公园动物园偷走了。最重要的是，他们也没有意识到这只鸟已经病了一个月，患有严重的呼吸道感染，且未经治疗。不知道这些，他们又是老烟枪。他们的公寓——
Inhospitable for an endangered sick parrot. So we picture the parrot sort of gasping and wheezing when it gets to Dawn and Ed's apartment, because we were.
对一只濒危的生病鹦鹉来说太不友好了。所以我们想象那只鹦鹉在来到道恩和埃德的公寓时气喘吁吁的样子，因为我们当时就是那么想的。
--When we went to their apartment to talk to them.
——当我们去他们的公寓和他们交谈时。
So Johnny gives them the parrot as payment for resume services, Eric and Alex say. And immediately there are things that Dawn does not like about this bird.
所以约翰尼把鹦鹉给他们抵偿简历服务的费用，埃里克和亚历克斯说。很快道恩就不喜欢这只鸟的某些地方了。
Well, first of all, it's not very lively. Well, it's had its wings clipped, and it's dying.
首先，它不太活泼。好吧，它的翅膀被剪了，而且它快死了。
And, most importantly, it doesn't talk.
最重要的是，它不会说话。
And that's all she wanted. She didn't want just a parrot. The only thing she wants in a parrot is that this parrot will speak with her. But they hatch a plan, they're going to barter this parrot.
而那正是她想要的。她想要的不仅仅是一只鹦鹉。她对鹦鹉唯一的愿望就是这只鹦鹉能跟她说话。但他们制定了一个计划，他们要拿这只鹦鹉去做交换。
And so they start calling stores, pet shops, bird stores.
于是他们开始给商店、宠物店、鸟店打电话。
Barter you mean for a better parrot?
交换？你是说换一只更好的鹦鹉？
For a parrot that talks. So when they call up and describe this bird to the stores, they all say, yeah right.
换一只会说话的鹦鹉。所以当他们打电话向商店描述这只鸟时，店员们都说，得了吧。
Oh, they understand the bird that it is.
哦，他们认出了那是什么鸟。
There is no possible way that you could have this bird. Now they get this reaction several times. But, finally, they put in a call to a shop called 33rd & Bird, which is located on 33rd Street right near the Empire State Building in Manhattan And the woman who picks up the phone there--
你根本不可能拥有这只鸟。他们多次得到这样的反应。但最终，他们给一家叫“33街与鸟”的店打了个电话，它位于曼哈顿帝国大厦附近的33街。接电话的那个女人——
Her name is Barbara.
她的名字叫芭芭拉。
Is that true?
是真的吗？
I believe so. I wouldn't swear to it.
我相信是吧。我不敢保证。
This is the one woman whose name we don't know, and she becomes central to this story.
这是唯一一个我们不知道名字的女人，而她成了这个故事的核心。
But we do know, she has sort of a volunteer night job at Beauty and the Beast, in addition to her pet store job.
但我们确实知道，除了宠物店的工作外，她在《美女与野兽》剧组还有一份志愿者兼职。
Beauty and the Beast, the Broadway show?
《美女与野兽》，那个百老汇演出？
The Broadway show, yeah. She's some kind of a stage grip.
那个百老汇演出，是的。她是某种舞台场务。
Where she works with--
她在那里和——
--a fellow animal lover.
——另一位动物爱好者一起工作。
Who works at--
在那儿工作的是——
--the Central Park Zoo.
——中央公园动物园。
So this woman, Barbara, who works at 33rd & Bird, because of this other friendship, knew all about the theft of the thick-billed parrot.
所以这个在“33街与鸟”工作的女人，芭芭拉，因为这种朋友关系，对厚嘴鹦鹉被盗的事一清二楚。
What are the odds?
几率有多大？
And the thing is, that she doesn't know, really, who she's talking to. Because, apparently, bird smuggling is a big, big deal. And there are people who will smuggle birds into this country, smuggle birds out of this country. There are people who are willing to buy birds on the black market.
问题是，她其实不知道自己在和谁说话。因为显然，鸟类走私是个很大的问题。有人把鸟私运进这个国家，有人把鸟私运出这个国家。有人愿意在黑市上买鸟。
And she's aware of this, working in a pet store.
而她在宠物店工作，对此很清楚。
Right, and, apparently, people who do it are ruthless criminals who will, she suspects, shoot you as soon as look at you.
没错，而且显然，做这种事的人是冷酷的罪犯，她怀疑他们杀起人来眼睛都不会眨。
And so this is who she thinks is on the other end of the phone.
所以这就是她认为电话另一头的人。
Can I just say, and maybe the whole bird smuggling thing is totally legit, but, OK, you're a professional criminal, or you're somebody who wants to to into the criminal game, and you have a choice. You could smuggle a tiny amount of cocaine across the border into the United States and make a lot of money, or you can carry a talking bird.
我能说一句吗？也许整个鸟类走私的事是合法的，但是，好吧，你是个职业罪犯，或者你想进入犯罪行当，你有一个选择。你可以走私少量可卡因过境进入美国并赚很多钱，或者你可以带一只会说话的鸟。
It might not be as big a problem as we think.
这可能不像我们想的那样是个大问题。
Right, OK.
好吧，行。
It is a legitimate, underground--
这是一个合法的、地下的——
Fear-- on her. And she's afraid. And she thinks she's dealing with serious, hardened criminals.
恐惧——在她身上。她很害怕。她以为她在和穷凶极恶的罪犯打交道。
So she calls the police, leaves a message about the stolen bird, very valuable bird smugglers, the whole thing. But this is New York City, nobody calls her back-- days pass. Meanwhile, Dawn keeps calling her-- remember, Barbara thinks that Dawn is a contraband bird smuggler up to no good-- Dawn keeps calling to ask just one thing--
所以她报了警，留了一条关于被偷的鸟、非常有价值的鸟类走私犯等等的消息。但这可是纽约市，没人回她电话——几天过去了。与此同时，道恩不停地给她打电话——记住，芭芭拉以为道恩是一个居心不良的走私犯——道恩不停地打电话问唯一一件事——
"Do you have a bird that talks?"
“你有会说话的鸟吗？”
The police won't call her back. She's going to rescue that poor bird herself. Alex and Eric say that she calls the cops one last time. There's a message saying that she's going in, here's the address.
警察还是不给她回电话。她要自己去救那只可怜的鸟。亚历克斯和埃里克说，她最后给警察打了一次电话。留下一条消息说她要行动了，地址如下。
If you never hear from me again, look for me here.
如果你再也收不到我的消息，就在这儿找我。
Look for me at this apartment building on 10th Avenue.
在第十大道的这栋公寓楼找我。
And she hangs up the phone. She picks up an empty cage, picks up a bird that talks.
然后她挂了电话。她拿起一个空笼子，抓起一只会说话的鸟。
Gets in a cab.
跳进一辆出租车。
She strides right to the elevator of this building where Ed and Dawn live in their smoky apartment with their wheezy bird.
她大步直奔电梯，来到埃德和道恩住的那栋楼，他们住在那烟雾缭绕的公寓里，养着那只喘鸣的鸟。
And, meanwhile, the precinct has finally checked their voicemail.
而与此同时，警察局终于查看了语音信箱。
And they're in the next elevator over.
他们在隔壁电梯里。
As she's riding up--
当她往上坐的时候——
They are about a minute in front of her.
他们比她快了大约一分钟。
And they're armed to the teeth.
而且他们全副武装。
They've got their SWAT gear on. They've got bulletproof vests--
他们穿着特警装备。他们穿着防弹背心——
Shotguns.
霰弹枪。
Riot helmets. They to think that they're going to bust up an international bird smuggling ring. And so when she gets off the elevator, all she sees is this massive SWAT team with one of those battering rams yelling, police, open up. And they bang down the door.
防暴头盔。他们认为他们要捣毁一个国际鸟类走私团伙。所以当她走出电梯时，她看到的只有一大群带着撞门槌的特警在尖叫：“警察，开门！”然后他们撞开了门。
And they take Ed by the scruff of the neck--
他们抓住埃德的后颈——
They start screaming, where's the bird, where's the bird-- the cops do.
他们开始尖叫，鸟在哪儿，鸟在哪儿——警察们。
They mace them.
他们喷了催泪瓦斯。
They-- OK, that's not true. In some tellings of the story, I have Dawn being yanked out of her chair and thrown to the ground, at the critical moment, when Barbara from 33rd & Bird walks in.
他们——好吧，那不是真的。在故事的某些版本中，我讲述的是当芭芭拉从“33街与鸟”走进来时，道恩被从椅子上拽下来扔到地上，在关键时刻。
Yeah, and carrying a birdcage--
是的，而且带着一个鸟笼——
Carrying a birdcage. And we do know that the following exchange took place. Dawn looks up, and she sees Barbara from 33rd & Bird, and she said, "did you bring me a bird that talks?"
带着一个鸟笼。我们确实知道发生了以下对话。道恩抬头看去，她看到了“33街与鸟”的芭芭拉，她说：“你给我带了只会说话的鸟吗？”
Is there any reason to believe that the part about the SWAT team in the story is true?
有什么理由相信故事中关于特警队的部分是真的吗？
No, not at all.
不，完全没有。
There is no SWAT team?
根本没有特警队？
It was probably, what, six detectives or something? That's actually-- when we went back and consulted our notes, we realized that the SWAT team part of it, that we'd been telling with more and more vigor--
那可能是什么，六个侦探之类的？事实上——当我们回去查看笔记时，我们意识到我们越讲越起劲的那部分特警队——
But in fact, it was in fact?
但实际上，实际上是？
Building security. With several police officers.
大楼保安。还有几个警察。
Several police officers. Six detectives flashing their badges, I think, is what we said at the time.
几个警察。我想我们当时说的是六个侦探出示了他们的徽章。
Johnny does get charged. Ed and Dawn--
约翰尼确实被指控了。埃德和道恩——
Ed and Dawn are let off. But Johnny gets, not only charged, but perp-walked. So the cops call the media and say--
埃德和道恩被放走了。但约翰尼不仅被指控，还被游街示众。所以警察打电话给媒体说——
A routine happening in New York City, where the cops will alert the media to the fact that the guy they just arrested is going to be walking between the cop car and the police precinct. His head is spinning at this point.
这是纽约市的一个常规发生的事情，警察会通知媒体，刚刚逮捕的人将在警车和警察局之间被带走。此时他的脑袋一片混乱。
Yeah, and he's dragged out of the car. There's like a phalanx of reporters. There's flashbulbs going off.
是的，他被从车里拖出来。有一大群记者。闪光灯闪个不停。
There's cameras in this face. Microphones being shoved right under his chin there.
有摄像机对着他的脸。麦克风直接塞在他下巴下面。
And keep in mind, he is an aspiring actor.
请记住，他是一个有志向的演员。
This is his moment in the sun, really.
这真的是他风光的时刻。
He's got the whole city right there. The whole city is basically watching.
他拥有整个城市。基本上整个城市都在看。
Somebody yells, "Why did you do it, Johnny?"
有人大喊：“约翰尼，你为什么要这么做？”
And Johnny, for absolutely no reason, yells back. He yells--
而约翰尼，完全没理由地大喊回敬。他喊道——
"I was going to make stew out of that bird." Which is not even remotely true, and it was the wrong thing to say if you're trying to engender sympathy somehow.
“我本来打算把那只鸟炖了。”这完全不是真的，而且如果你想博取同情的话，这是最不该说的话。
Johnny went to jail. And Ed and Dawn were left mystified by this whole thing. But the parrot went back to the zoo and died within about three or four days, I think. It had been in bad shape, and they couldn't save it.
约翰尼坐牢了。埃德和道恩对这一切感到莫名其妙。但鹦鹉被送回了动物园，我想在三四天内就死了。它之前状况很糟，他们没能救下它。
So that was Eric and Alex's famous bird story. And after we talked they did something they'd been wanting to do for a long time. Now that they're experienced newspaper reporters, they went out and tried to contact all the people in the story to figure out, once and for all, what parts of the story are true, and what parts are just embellishments that they have been added over the years. Here's what they discovered.
那就是埃里克和亚历克斯著名的鸟故事。在谈话结束后，他们做了他们想做很久的事。现在他们是经验丰富的新闻记者了，他们出去并试图联系故事中的所有人，一劳永逸地弄清楚故事的哪些部分是真实的，哪些是多年来添加的润色。以下是他们发现的。
The lady from the bird store, who turns out to be named Michelle not Barbara, she was completely unfindable. Dawn, the woman in the wheelchair, she died in 2002. The guy who she lived with, Ed, he was happy to talk. But he did not remember much of the story.
鸟店的那个女士，名字原来是米歇尔而不是芭芭拉，根本找不到。道恩，那个坐轮椅的女人，在2002年去世了。她住在一起的那个家伙埃德，很高兴谈谈。但他记不起故事的太多细节了。
With some prodding, as best as he could, he confirmed a lot of the details of Eric and Alex's story. For example, the reason that he got the bird from Johnny, the smoking, the police raid-- which, by the way, he remembered as six policemen. He also talked very sweetly about how much he loved Dawn and missed her.
在催促下，他尽可能地证实了埃里克和亚历克斯故事的许多细节。例如，他从约翰尼那里得到鸟的原因、吸烟、警察突袭——顺便说一下，他记得是六个警察。他还非常甜蜜地谈到他有多爱道恩，多想念她。
And I just left one person to contact, Johnny.
我只剩下一个人没联系了，约翰尼。
It was the Virgin Cola-- the release for Virgin Cola after party. And I was with a couple of buds, drinking and smoking weed.
那是维珍可乐——维珍可乐会后的派对。我和几个哥们儿在一起，喝着酒，抽着大麻。
John Davilla, as he likes to be called these days, is now out of prison. For bird theft, he was actually only put on parole, but then he violated his parole by failing a urine test, and got sent to prison for 11 months. Now he is trying to get acting work out in Los Angeles. And when he talked to Eric and Alex he contradicted or threw into question nearly every fact they thought they had from years ago.
约翰·达维拉，现在他喜欢这样称呼自己，已经出狱了。因为偷鸟，他实际上只被判了缓刑，但后来因为没通过尿检违反了缓刑规定，被送进监狱关了11个月。现在他正在洛杉矶寻找表演工作。当他和埃里克及亚历克斯交谈时，他反驳或质疑了几乎所有他们认为多年来早已确定的事实。
John says that he did not take the bird home on the subway. He did not live in Bay Ridge. He did not barter the bird for a resume with Ed. He gave it as a gift, though Ed says otherwise. He did not cut the bird's wings with scissors, he says. He did not sneak into the zoo alone. And, finally, it was not him who stole the parrot.
约翰说他并没有把鸟带上地铁。他没住在湾脊区。他没有为了简历和埃德交换鸟。那是他送的礼物，虽然埃德说是别的原因。他说他没用剪刀剪鸟的翅膀。他不是一个人偷偷溜进动物园的。最后，偷鹦鹉的人不是他。
There was this cute little bird, and my homeboy snagged it, and put it in his jacket and walked out with it. And we all just like looked at each other and was like, let's go.
有一只可爱的小鸟，我兄弟把它顺走了，揣进夹克里带了出来。我们大家面面相觑，心想，走吧。
You and your buddies, it's not you alone?
你和你的兄弟们，不是你一个人？
No, there was five of us.
不，我们有五个人。
Do you remember what you told us at the time?
你还记得你当时告诉我们什么吗？
No, I don't remember.
不，我不记得了。
OK, so I'm going to read you some of this story, OK John? It was eerily quiet, save for some splashing from the sea lion pool. Quote, "It was like there was this [BLEEP] mist," Davilla said, speaking slowly and dramatically. "And the bird was there." You took the bird out of its cage, you said. The bird looked at you. Quote, "I said wow, what are you looking at man? Come on man, let's go. And we went."
好吧，我要读给你听听这个故事，约翰，好吗？“周围出奇的安静，只有海狮池的水花声。”引文，“就好像有一层[哔]雾，”达维拉说着，语速缓慢且充满戏剧感。“鸟就在那儿。”你说你把鸟从笼子里拿了出来。鸟看着你。引文，“我说哇，伙计你在看什么？来吧伙计，我们走吧。我们就走了。”
Yeah, that was a dream I had the day after the party. And I remember that dream. And I remember thinking that I gotta stop smoking pot, man.
是的，那是我在派对后做的梦。我记得那个梦。我记得心想我得停止抽大麻了，伙计。
I'm awfully disappointed, John.
我非常失望，约翰。
What did you expect?
你期望什么？
I don't know.
我不知道。
What did you expect?
你期望什么？
I thought there was a point.
我以为是有意义的。
Eric is very disappointed here.
埃里克在这里非常失望。
I feel cheated, man.
我感觉被骗了，伙计。
Well did you think he really had the conversation with the Bird?
好吧，你真的认为他和那只鸟有过对话吗？
No, but I thought he thought he did.
不，但我以为他以为他有过。
I think I did, actually, to be honest with you.
老实说，我以为我有过。
No, come on Johnny, you're just telling us what we want to hear.
不，得了吧约翰尼，你只是在说我们想听的。
You're making stuff up.
你是在编造。
No, it's a true story, man. And when they ask you, you say it's a true story.
不，这是个真实的故事，伙计。当他们问你时，你就说是真实的故事。
So the version of the story that they have always told, that they have wondered if it's true, that's the version of the story they're going to have live with. Because nobody, nobody in this world besides them has cared enough about this story to remember it. The facts will stay forever unconfirmable.
所以他们一直讲述的、一直怀疑是否真实的版本，就是他们必须忍受的故事版本。因为除了他们之外，世界上没有人关心这个故事并记得它。事实将永远无法证实。
And when I ask Eric and Alex why this story has stuck with them, and why they've been retelling this story for years, long after they went on to become real reporters for real newspapers, this story is still their favorite story? They truthfully do not have much of an answer. Mostly they say, they just liked everybody who they interviewed for this story. Everybody told them such amazing things. And yes, this is a story about a crime. And yes, the parrot dies. But nobody is really out to hurt anybody in this story or do any harm, including Johnny.
当我问埃里克和亚历克斯为什么这个故事一直困扰着他们，为什么他们在多年后成为真正的报社记者后，依然年复一年地重述这个故事，而这依然是他们最喜欢的故事？他们确实没能给出多少答案。他们大部分时间说，他们只是喜欢他们为这个故事采访过的每一个人。每一个人都告诉了他们如此神奇的事情。是的，这是一个关于犯罪的故事。是的，鹦鹉死了。但在这个故事中，没有人真的想伤害任何人或做任何恶事，包括约翰尼。
There is a sort of innocence. He wasn't out to make money off the thing. He didn't want to kill it. He loved it.
有一种天真。他不是为了靠这东西赚钱。他没想杀了它。他爱它。
I think the parrot made everybody in this story take leave of their senses including the two of you.
我想那只鹦鹉让故事里的每个人都失去了理智，包括你们两个。
I think that that has never crossed my mind before today, but I think you might be absolutely right on that.
我想这在今天之前从未在我的脑海中闪过，但我认为你可能是绝对正确的。
Like look at this. Everybody's going out of their way for the parrot. He takes the parrot for no good reason. The next two people take the parrot really for reasons that make no sense at all. They take a parrot to distract a woman from talking to her husband, or boyfriend, whatever. And then the two of you, for no reason at all, you're never going to make money, you're never going to write a story. Just keep reporting this story for months for no one.
你看。每个人都为了这只鹦鹉不遗余力。他毫无理由地带走了鹦鹉。接下来的两个人带走鹦鹉的理由真的完全没意义。他们带走鹦鹉是为了分散一个女人注意，让她不去理会她的丈夫或男朋友之类的。然后你们两个，完全没有理由，你们永远赚不到钱，永远写不出报道。只是为了没人的故事连续几个月不断报道这个故事。
It makes no sense, our behavior. And we wouldn't have done it if it had been a kitten.
我们的行为完全没道理。如果那是一只小猫，我们是不会这么做的。
I don't know man, a kitten?
我不知道伙计，一只小猫？
When we tell the story over and over, by the way, a lot of people, they think there's a punch line at the end.
顺便说一下，当我们一遍又一遍地讲这个故事时，很多人认为最后有个笑点。
And there's never a punch line.
从来没有笑点。
The story just sort of peters out.
故事就是那样逐渐消失了。
Well, not necessarily.
嗯，不一定。
Maybe you need a punchline. You need a punchline.
也许你需要一个笑点。你需要一个笑点。
We actually got some suggestions last night.
我们昨晚确实得到了一些建议。
From the movie star, he sort of suggested a punchline.
从那位电影明星那儿，他稍微建议了一个笑点。
Who was the movie star?
电影明星是谁？
Topher Grace, the guy from That '70s Show.
托弗·格瑞斯，《70年代秀》里的那个家伙。
Wait, and Topher Grace had the suggestion for the ending?
等等，托弗·格瑞斯对结局有建议？
He did, he had an excellent suggestion.
是的，他有一个绝妙的建议。
The scene is the apartment, the police barge in--
场景在公寓里，警察冲了进来——
Dawn is on the floor with a jackboot on her neck. And the cops haul everyone away--
道恩在地上，脖子上被踩了一只军靴——
There's one detective who's sort of--
警察把所有人都带走了——
--left alone in the apartment.
有一个侦探，他有点——
He's the one charged with taking the bird, taking possession of the bird. So he opens the cage. And he looks at the parrot, and he says, "You want to go? " And the parrot says, "Yeah." And he says, "Let's go."
——独自留在公寓里。
And, scene.
他是被指派带走这只鸟、拥有这只鸟的人。于是他打开笼子。他看着鹦鹉，说：“你想走吗？”鹦鹉说：“想。”于是他说：“那我们走吧。”
Alex Lane is a staff writer for the Star Ledger in Newark. Eric Holm just started at Bloomberg News. In those jobs, they both do factual reporting.
场景结束。
Coming up, so two pigs, a parrot, a Jew, a Canadian, and David Sedaris walk into the second half of the show. And the first pig says to the second pig, is it me or do these coming-up-next announcements just keep getting longer? More in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
亚历克斯·莱恩是纽瓦克《明星纪事报》的专职作家。埃里克·霍尔姆刚在彭博新闻社开始工作。在这些工作中，他们都做事实报道。
Well, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, the parrot and the pot-bellied pig. Stories where these two humble animals are just trying to lead their animal lives and simply by being alive they create all kinds of havoc around them, without ever intending to.
接下来，两头猪、一只鹦鹉、一个犹太人、一个加拿大人和大卫·塞达里斯走进节目的后半段。第一头猪对第二头猪说，是我个人的错觉吗，还是这些“接下来”的通告变得越来越长了？从芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际公司继续我们的节目，稍后回来。
We've arrived at Act Two of our show, Act Two, Pig. Well, one of our regular contributors here on This American Life, Jonathan Goldstein has been hosting a new radio show on the Canadian Broadcasting Corporation called Wiretap. And he has this story of people and animals.
嗯，这是《这就是美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目，“鹦鹉与大肚猪”。在这个故事中，这两只卑微的动物只是试图过它们的动物生活，仅仅因为活着，它们就造成了各种混乱，却从没想过要这样做。
The other day, my friend Tony called me up and told me he had the funniest story for the radio. All he'd say was that involved him, his ex-girlfriend, and a road trip they made with a pot-bellied pig. Before Tony would tell me anything further, he said he wanted me to be running a tape recorder. This way, he said, when it played on the radio there'd be my surprised laughter egging him on.
我们来到了节目的第二幕，第二幕，猪。我们《这就是美国生活》的常驻撰稿人之一乔纳森·戈德斯坦一直在加拿大广播公司主持一个名为“监听”的新广播节目。他有这个关于人和动物的故事。
But here's the thing. I hardly ever laugh. If there's one thing I could change about myself, it would be that. Working in radio, I wish I had the kind of free and easy laugh that felt like an arm around the shoulder. A laugh that said, speak on you darling clown, I am so with you. Instead, I produce silences that, rather than encourage, make a storyteller feel like they're being scrutinized. Or worse, like I just put the phone down to go out and put more change in the parking meter.
前几天，我朋友托尼打电话告诉我，他有一个最有趣的广播故事。他只说涉及他、他的前女友，以及他们带着一头大肚猪进行的公路旅行。在托尼告诉我任何进一步细节之前，他说他希望我正在录音。这样，他说，当在广播里播出时，会有我惊讶的笑声在鼓动他。
So Tony started telling me the story, and, as usual, I wasn't laughing. But I started to realize that this time was different. For once, I wasn't laughing because the story wasn't funny. But any way, I'm getting ahead of myself. I'll let Tony tell the story.
但问题是。我几乎从来不笑。如果我能改变自己的一点，那就是这一点。在广播工作，我希望我能有一种轻松自如的笑声，感觉像肩膀上的拥抱。一种笑声说，讲吧，你这个可爱的滑稽小丑，我完全跟你在一起。相反，我制造的沉默，与其说是鼓励，倒不如让讲故事的人觉得他们正被审视。或者更糟，就像我刚刚放下电话去给停车收费表投币去了。
I guess it kind of marked, pretty much, the end of my relationship with Susan, my last girlfriend. We'd been going out for about four years, and the relationship was on its last legs and had been for, pretty much, about a year.
所以托尼开始给我讲故事，照常，我没笑。但我开始意识到这次不同了。这一次，我没笑是因为故事不怎么有趣。但不管怎样，我讲得太快了。还是让托尼讲这个故事吧。
Susan is an animal enthusiast, lover. She is always trying to save something. She's always online looking for rescue animals that she obviously, she can't possibly rescue any of them, actually. Or maybe one or two, but she's obsessed with it.
我想这基本上标志着我和苏珊，我最后一个女朋友，关系的结束。我们交往了大约四年，关系一直处于强弩之末，基本上已经维持了大约一年了。
And there was a couple that we knew that about a year ago or a year and a half ago, they got a pot-bellied pig, a baby pot-bellied pig.
苏珊是一个动物爱好者，热爱者。她总是试图拯救某些东西。她总是在网上寻找救援动物，而显然，她根本不可能拯救任何一只。或者也许一两只，但她对此很痴迷。
Are they farmers?
有一对我们认识的夫妇，大约一年前或一年半前，他们得到了一头大肚猪，一头小大肚猪。
No. They're just like regular city folk. One of them had a head shop-- just like scenesters. And I guess, like my first reaction was that's kind of, I don't know, that's kind of stupid. You don't bring a pig home to the city, to a house. It just seemed like kind of a scenester thing to do like, hey, the guy got a pig.
他们是农民吗？
But, so they got a pig. And it was really cute. And they showed me pictures and convinced me that it was pretty smart and fun. And it was OK running around the house and in their yard, and stuff like that.
不。他们就像普通的城市人。其中一个开了一家头饰店——就像赶时髦的人。我想，我的第一反应是那有点，我不知道，那有点蠢。你不应该把猪带回城市、带回房子里。那看起来就像赶时髦的人会做的事，嘿，那家伙养了一头猪。
What was the pig's name?
但，他们养了一头猪。它真的很可爱。他们给我看照片，并说服我它相当聪明且有趣。在家里和院子里到处跑都没问题，之类的。
Pig's name was Warren. Nothing was heard from the pig or the couple for a while. And then there were some rumblings. I started talking to them. And well, it's not going so well. You know he's ruining the place, and he's out of control and all this stuff.
那头猪叫什么名字？
And before long, Susan was on the case to make sure that he found a good home and happy life. She called around and found a place, an animal sanctuary, outside of Montreal. And they were like, yes, of course bring the pig. And so Susan made arrangements to bring the pig there.
猪的名字叫沃伦。那头猪或那对夫妇有一阵子没消息了。然后有一些传言。我开始和他们交谈。嗯，情况不太好。你知道它正在毁掉那个地方，它失控了，等等之类的。
I know what's about to happen, and I don't want to have anything to do with it. And, of course, I'm approached to do the job, to drive this pig to Montreal.
没过多久，苏珊就开始确保它能找到一个好家和幸福生活。她到处打电话，在蒙特利尔郊外找到了一个地方，一个动物庇护所。他们说，是的，当然，把猪带过来。于是苏珊安排把猪带去那里。
In your car.
我知道接下来会发生什么，我不想和它有任何关系。当然，我被要求去做这个工作，开车把这头猪送到蒙特利尔。
In my car. And I know, I know at this point in my heart, in my gut, that I'm going to be doing this, because you can't get in Susan's way when she's trying to save an animal. She's unstoppable. And in my mind, it was very clear. Drive with pig to Montreal or deal with the repercussions of not doing that for about a week.
用你的车。
Give me a sense of how big this pig is, like, how much does it weigh?
用我的车。我知道，我心里、直觉里清楚，我非做不可，因为当苏珊试图拯救动物时，你没法拦住她。她是不可阻挡的。在我心里，这很明确。开着车带着猪去蒙特利尔，或者承担接下来一周不这么做的后果。
250 pounds? It's a pot-bellied pig. It's not like a big-ass, sort of, regular pork pig. He was just kind of like a children's book pig. And hairy-- pot-bellied pigs they have fur.
告诉我这头猪有多大，它有多重？
Are they pink?
250磅？它是大肚猪。它不像那种笨重的、普通的猪。它就像那种儿童书里的猪。而且多毛——大肚猪有皮毛。
No, they're kind of brown. So OK, let's put the pig in the cage and let's go do it. And within a couple of minutes realized the cage is not going to fit in my car. There's no way. So like OK, well, we'll just put the pig in. We'll cover the back seat with garbage bags and whatever, and it'll be fine. And at that point, I'm just not thinking. I want to just get this over with. Let's just get the pig in the car. Let's drive. Let's go.
它们是粉色的吗？
But we did. We covered the back seat and we started to drive. The first 20 minutes we're kind of all right. The pig was hanging out in the back. Susan was feeding him and petting him. And everything was fine.
不，它们有点棕色。好吧，把猪放进笼子，我们去吧。几分钟内我就意识到笼子根本塞不进我的车。没门。所以好吧，我们直接把猪放进去就行了。我们用垃圾袋之类的把后座盖住，应该没问题。那时候，我什么都没想。我只想快点结束这一切。快把猪放进车里。开车。走吧。
Then about-- probably about 45 minutes into it, the pig started to get more and more agitated. We ran out of food. We had to stop and get some more food. We got like a big bag of bird seed and just a couple of other varieties of dog biscuits and whatever. We stopped at places. They didn't have pig food per se, because people don't usually keep pigs.
但我们确实这么做了。我们盖住了后座，开始行驶。前20分钟还行。猪在后座待着。苏珊在喂它、抚摸它。一切都很好。
We're driving, and I'm starting to realize that, we're both starting to realize that Warren, the pig, is getting more and more agitated. Like he's not happy. He is getting really restless. He's becoming less and less interested in the food. He is getting more and more persistent about getting up to the front seat. At this point, I can sense the pig's head popping over my right shoulder, sort of snapping. And trying to get over to my left shoulder with the window, and then back over my right shoulder and snapping. And soon had a full body hold on it, trying to keep it away from me.
大约——大概过了45分钟，猪开始变得越来越焦躁。我们没食物了。我们得停下来买些食物。我们买了一大袋鸟食和几种狗饼干之类的。我们在一些地方停下来。它们没有专门的猪饲料，因为人们通常不养猪。
And this sort of thing really started to turn into something else. I mean, you're in a situation like that with somebody, I suppose the kind of mature, adult, useful thing to do would be to accept the you're in a situation. But I was not happy. I let it be known.
我们开着车，我开始意识到，我们俩都开始意识到沃伦，那头猪，变得越来越焦躁。它不开心。它变得真的很不安。它对食物越来越不感兴趣了。它越来越执着于爬到前座。此时，我能感觉到猪头从我右肩冒出来，某种程度上在乱撞。并试图越过我的左肩去碰窗户，然后又回到我的右肩乱撞。很快它全身都压过来了，我试图把它推开。
And most importantly, and most significantly for Susan, I was not laughing. Because after a certain point, she started to find it funny, like most people do. Most people start to find story funny around this point, even sooner. I didn't find it funny at all.
这事开始变得有点变味了。我的意思是，如果你和某人处于那种境地，我想成熟、成人、有用的做法应该是接受你们处于那种境地。但我很不高兴。我让它表现出来了。
The more she laughed, the more funny she found it, the more upset and angry I got. So she had the pig to deal with, and then, I guess, she had me to deal with. Finally, I came up with the idea that what we needed was a barricade to put between us and the pig, to keep it the pig in the backseat, to keep us from getting hurt. Whatever happened to the back of the car happened at this point because we're in survival mode.
而且最重要的是，对苏珊而言最重大的，我没有笑。因为到了一定程度，她开始觉得好笑，就像大多数人一样。大多数人从这时开始觉得故事好笑，甚至更早。我一点也不觉得好笑。
We're driving around behind strip malls looking for a big piece of cardboard. Finally, we found what looked like something that a refrigerator been in. And I grabbed it. It was soaked in garbage, and it was raining that day. And I opened the car door. Susan is holding the pig back with all her strength. And I jammed this big piece of cardboard, slid it in like when magicians-- when they cut people in half, just slid it into the car, with all my strength, as far as it could go. And I closed the door.
她笑得越多，她觉得越好笑，我就越沮丧和生气。所以她得对付猪，然后，我想，她得对付我。最后，我想出一个主意，我们需要一个路障放在我们和猪之间，把猪挡在后座，以防我们受伤。车后座发生了什么已经不重要了，因为我们处于生存模式。
And it worked. And the funny thing is, he didn't even fight. As soon as the barricade went up, he just gave up. We drove the rest of the way to the farm and cut him loose. And he joined his brothers and sisters, his new brothers and sisters, which were these gigantic, fat pot-bellied pigs. Which, I guess, in a short time he'd be like them.
我们在条状购物中心后面开车转悠，寻找一大块纸板。最后，我们找到了看起来像装过冰箱的东西。我抓住了它。它被垃圾浸透了，那天还在下雨。我打开车门。苏珊用尽全力拦住猪。我把这块大纸板塞进去，就像魔术师——当他们把人切成两半时，我用尽全力把它塞进车里，尽可能深地塞进去。然后我关上了门。
And was that, I mean was that like a beautiful moment?
奏效了。有趣的是，它甚至没反抗。路障一立起来，它就放弃了。我们开了剩下的路程到达农场，把它放了出来。它加入了它的兄弟姐妹，它新的兄弟姐妹，那些巨大、肥胖的大肚猪。我想，很快它也会像它们一样了。
I wouldn't say it was beautiful. I felt relieved that the pig was out of my car. And we broke up within a month of this incident.
那，我的意思是那是一个美丽的时刻吗？
Do you think that this was the straw that broke the camel's back for Susan?
我不会说它很美。猪从我车里出来时我感到如释重负。在这件事发生后的一个月内我们就分手了。
She actually said as much. She just said, I can't be with somebody who can't find the humor in the moment in something like that, no matter how dangerous it is, no matter how stupid or crazy, or wrong it is. That's not how I want to live my life.
你认为这是压死骆驼的最后一根稻草吗？
And when he told you that, did you feel like, I could change?
她确实这么说了。她只是说，我不能和一个在那种时刻找不到幽默感的人在一起，不管它有多危险，不管它有多愚蠢、疯狂或错误。那不是我想过的生活。
I wanted to change, but I could not possibly enjoy life as much as she does. I think she had a point. And I think she was right about me getting too upset over that and not seeing the humor in it.
当他告诉你这些时，你觉得，我可以改变吗？
The thing about me and Susan-- Susan loves it when things go wrong, because that's when the real fun begins. That's when the real wackiness and zaniness, and the hilarity ensues. And she just thrives on that. She just loves it.
我想改变，但我不可能像她那样享受生活。我认为她有道理。我认为关于我因为那事太沮丧而没看到幽默感这一点，她是正确的。
I don't. I don't. I like it when things go right. I like things to be relatively under control. And the thing I resented about Susan was that she was constantly trying to pull me into her sort of way of having fun. In a sense, Susan was trying to help me have some fun. There's no question in my mind that the way that I react to situations that I'm unhappy with, unhappy to be in, disapprove of, is really, really similar to the way my father used to react to me all the time.
关于我和苏珊的事——苏珊喜欢事情出错，因为那是真正乐趣开始的时候。那是真正疯狂、滑稽、搞笑的时候。她对此充满活力。她就是喜欢。
Like, how do you mean?
我不。我不。我喜欢事情顺利进行。我喜欢事情相对在控制之下。我对苏珊感到怨恨的是，她不断试图把我拉进她那种找乐子的方式中。在某种意义上，苏珊试图帮我找点乐子。我毫无疑问地认为，我对我不快乐的、不愿身处的、不赞同的情况所做出的反应，真的和我的父亲一直对我所做的反应非常相似。
Well, kind of stern, disapproving, punitive, making you feel stupid, making you feel like you're doing stuff wrong. I think the defining moment between me and my father was Halloween. I think I was nine. And I went to my friend Sunny's house, he lived down the street, and he had a makeup kit. And he made me up. I don't know. I guess it was some combo of drag and weird clown thing, and zombie. I don't know. We just made it up.
你是说，怎么个相似法？
He made me all up, and I put on a dress. And I ran out into the street and started knocking on everybody's door and just like, I don't know, just yelling and screaming and being an idiot. Just like I'm going to cross from blah, blah, blah running down the street, and, before I knew it, I was at my door.
嗯，有点严厉、不赞同、惩罚性，让你感觉很蠢，让你觉得你正在做错事。我认为我和我父亲之间的决定性时刻是万圣节。我想我那时九岁。我去了我朋友桑尼家，他住在那条街的尽头，他有一个化妆包。他给我化了妆。我不知道。我猜是那种变装、奇怪的小丑装和僵尸的结合。我不知道。我们只是随便化了一下。
And knocked on the door, and I was so out of control at that point. I didn't give a [BLEEP]. I didn't care about anything. I didn't care that I was knocking on my door. My father answered the door. And like a moment of shock. And he grabbed me and pulled me in and started smacking me. Because I was embarrassing him. Because I was doing something completely stupid and embarrassing and having fun.
他把我也化了，我穿上一件裙子。我跑到街上，开始敲每一扇门，只是——我不知道，只是大喊大叫，像个白痴。就像我就要横穿马路，跑在街上，还没回过神，我就到了我家门口。
If you try to control everything and OK, this is going to work like that. Well you break up with people. If a best friend is too much of a hassle, just crazy at text, and three hours on the phone every two days, blah, blah, blah. After a while, you cut everything out of your life. And then you get lonely and bored. And I have fewer and fewer stories to tell. And I mean, what do you do when you don't have enough stories to tell, is you go looking for trouble.
我敲了门，那时候我已经完全失控了。我不在乎任何事。我不在乎我是不是在敲我家的门。我父亲开了门。那一瞬间的震惊。他抓起我，把我拽进去，开始打我。因为我让他尴尬了。因为我在做一件完全愚蠢、尴尬且在找乐子的事。
How so?
如果你试图控制一切，好吧，事情会这样进行。那么你会和人分手。如果最好的朋友太烦人，短信太疯狂，两天三小时的电话，等等之类的。过了一段时间，你切断了生活中的一切。然后你就变得孤独和无聊了。我有越来越少的故事可讲。我的意思是，当你没有足够的故事可讲时，你就去寻找麻烦。
Well, I'm just like wandering around at night, walking by bars, looking for people to pick fights with, just somebody that will annoy me or irritate me. He looks good, I'm going to hang around and see what he's saying. It's a bringing to bear my frustration onto an outside thing that deserves to have my fury unleashed upon it.
怎么讲？
Do you miss Susan?
嗯，我只是晚上到处游荡，走过酒吧，寻找可以吵架的人，只是某人会惹恼我或激怒我。他看起来不错，我要过去看看他在说什么。这是一种把我的沮丧带到一个值得我愤怒发泄的外在事物上。
I do. I miss her because I was close to her, and I love her, and I think she's a wonderful person. I love the way she dealt with people. And I loved the way she was. And I wanted to absorb some of that. I wanted some of that to rub off on me. I want some of that.
你想念苏珊吗？
And did you get it?
我想念。我想念她，因为我曾经和她很亲近，我爱她，我认为她是一个美好的人。我喜欢她与人相处的方式。我喜欢她那种样子。我想吸收其中的一些。我想让它的一些特质影响我。我想要一些那种东西。
I have some of that.
你得到了吗？
What do you think that she saw in you that was alluring to her?
我得到了一些。
I don't know. I don't know. Maybe I was another animal for her to save.
你认为她看到了你身上什么吸引她的地方？
Jonathan Goldstein's CBC radio show Wiretap is at www.cdc.ca/Wiretap. Thanks also to his friend Tony Asimakopoulos and to Sarah Gilbert.
我不知道。我不知道。也许我是她拯救的另一只动物。
Act Three, Combo Platter. Starting out today we have had a story about a parrot, and we've had a story about a pig. And to end today's show, we have this story from David Sedaris.
乔纳森·戈德斯坦的CBC广播节目“监听”网址是www.cdc.ca/Wiretap。也感谢他的朋友托尼·阿西马科普洛斯和萨拉·吉尔伯特。
When asked why she'd chosen to become a journalist, the parrot was known to cock her head a half an inch to the right, and pause for a moment before repeating the question. "Why did I choose to become a journalist? Well, I guess what really drives me is the money-- that and the free booze." It killed her to follow this with, "I was just joking about the money."
第三幕，大杂烩。今天一开始我们讲了一个关于鹦鹉的故事，我们还讲了一个关于猪的故事。为了结束今天的节目，我们有大卫·塞达里斯的故事。
The paper she worked at was called The Eagle. And she wrote for the Tempo section, which was later renamed Lifestyles, and was now titled, simply, Living. Most of her stories were little more than puff-pieces. Interview the wealthy tortoise who'd shelled out money for the new speedway. Cover the benefit gala for ringworm, or heartworm or the earthworm or anti-defamation league.
当被问及为什么选择成为一名记者时，那只鹦鹉习惯把头向右歪半英寸，并停顿一会儿再重复这个问题。“我为什么选择成为一名记者？好吧，我想真正驱动我的是钱——那和免费的酒。”接下来跟着说“我只是在开钱的玩笑”让她极其难受。
She wanted an opportunity to show her chops and finally got her break when a pot-bellied pig took over as director of the local art museum. The Eagle wanted something simple, 300 words tops, but the parrot thought differently. It scheduled a long lunch. Her guest arrived on time, and after ordering they got down to business.
她工作的报社叫《鹰报》。她为“节奏”版块写稿，后来改名为“生活方式”，现在简称为“生活”。她的大多数报道不过是些软文。采访花钱修建新高速公路的富有乌龟。报道针对癣、心虫、蚯蚓或反诽谤联盟的慈善晚会。
"So," the parrot began, "it's a long way from Ho Chi Minh City to the much coveted director's chair of a noted museum. I'd like you to reminisce about the journey a little."
她想要一个展现身手的机会，当一头大肚猪接管了当地艺术博物馆的馆长职务时，她终于得到了机会。《鹰报》想要简单的报道，300字以内，但鹦鹉不这么想。它安排了一顿漫长的午餐。她的客人准时到达，点完餐后他们进入正题。
"I'm sorry," the pig said. "But I've never been to Ho Chi Minh City."
“那么，”鹦鹉开始说，“从胡志明市到知名博物馆梦寐以求的馆长位置，路途遥远。我想让你稍微回忆一下那段旅程。”
"But you are from that region are you not?"
“抱歉，”猪说，“但我从未去过胡志明市。”
"No," the pig told her, not at all.
“但你来自那个地区，不是吗？”
The parrot ran her fat, black tongue over the ragged edge of her upper beak. "I don't mean to contradict you," she said, "but I have done a little leg work, and it seems that you're officially registered with your health care provider as a Vietnamese pot-bellied pig. So let's turn our thoughts eastward, shall we, and talk about your past."
“不，”猪对她说，完全不是。
"Technically, yes, I am a Vietnamese pot-bellied pig," the museum director said. "But that's just a silly formality. The fact is that I was born in this country, as were my parents and their parents before them."
鹦鹉用她那肥硕的黑舌头舔过上喙的粗糙边缘。“我不是要反驳你，”她说，“但我做了一点调查，看来你在医疗保健提供者那里正式登记为越南大肚猪。所以让我们把思绪转到东方，好吗，聊聊你的过去。”
"I see," the parrot said. And she scratched the words self-hating onto her notepad. "So how will your ethnicity reflect itself in regards to our museum? Can we expect to see more Oriental art, a pricey new Ming wing, perhaps some big Treasures of The Emperor extravaganza?"
“技术上讲，是的，我是越南大肚猪，”博物馆馆长说。“但那只是一个愚蠢的形式。事实上我出生在这个国家，我的父母以及他们之前的父母也是。”
"Nothing's planned," the pig said.
“我明白了，”鹦鹉说。并在笔记本上写下“自我厌恶”几个字。“那么你的民族身份将如何反映在我们的博物馆上？我们能期待看到更多东方艺术、昂贵的明朝展区，或者一些关于皇帝珍宝的大型盛会吗？”
"But you wouldn't rule it out?"
“还没计划，”猪说。
"Well, no, not completely, but--"
“但你不会排除这个可能性？”
"That's all I wanted to know," the parrot said. And at that moment, their lunch all arrived.
“嗯，不，不完全是，但是——”
It was she who had made the reservation, and, in a moment of inspiration, she decided they'd go to Old Saigon. The fact that it was her idea would not be mentioned in the article. Nor would she add that the pig had never in his life used a pair of chopsticks, and that he gripped them, one in each hoof, as if they were screwdrivers.
“这正是我想要的，”鹦鹉说。就在那一刻，他们的午餐都上齐了。
During the meal, a few blades of lemongrass for him, a Mekong platter for her. They talked about this and that, but she wasn't really engaged, busy as she was dreaming up a headline. Museum Takes on Asian a Slant was good, but she'd have to fight hard to get it past her editor who despised, what she called, word play.
是她定的位置，灵机一动，她决定去“旧西贡”。它是她的主意这一事实不会在文章中提及。她也不会补充说这只猪一生从未使用过筷子，他两只蹄子各握住一只，就好像那是螺丝起子一样。
When their lunch was over, the pig trotted back to the museum, and the parrot headed down to the VFW Hall, where she hoped to round out her article. There she spoke to a red-shouldered hawk, who hadn't actually fought in Vietnam but might have had the war lasted just a few weeks longer.
用餐期间，他吃了几片柠檬草，她吃了一盘湄公河拼盘。他们聊东聊西，但她并不真的感兴趣，忙着构思标题。“博物馆采取亚洲偏见”很好，但她必须费力才能让编辑通过，编辑蔑视她所称的“文字游戏”。
"I could have practically been killed over there, and now one of them is coming to my museum trying to tell me what art I should look at?"
午餐结束后，猪慢跑回博物馆，鹦鹉前往退伍军人协会大厅，她希望在那里充实她的文章。在那里，她采访了一只红肩鹰，它实际上没在越南打过仗，但如果战争再持续几周的话，它可能就上了。
"I know it," the parrot said.
“我本来差点就在那边送命，现在其中一个要到我的博物馆来试图告诉我看什么艺术？”
The article was due the following morning, and she stayed up all night in order to finish it. Her editor scowled at the bulk of pages but softened after the first read through saying, " Good work, you," and, "Maybe we should send this over to the city desk."
“我知道，”鹦鹉说。
The eventual headline was no masterpiece, Pot-bellied Museum Director Stirs Controversy. But the parrot was so relieved to move out of the Living section that they could have called it Mud and she wouldn't have cared. As for the pig, he wasn't nearly as upset as she thought he would be. Rather than threatening a lawsuit or demanding a retraction, he phoned to say that he was disappointed. "Deeply disappointed," were his exact words.
文章在次日早晨截止，她通宵未眠为了完成它。编辑对那一叠页数皱起眉头，但在读完第一遍后心软了，说，“做得好，你，”还有，“也许我们该把它发到城市版块。”
The parrot reached for a pen, hoping for quotes that might lead to a second article. "Is that all you have to say?" she asked.
最终的标题算不上杰作，《大肚猪博物馆馆长引发争议》。但鹦鹉太高兴能从“生活”版块调出来，就算把它叫做“泥巴”她也不会在意。至于那头猪，他不像她想的那样生气。他没有威胁要诉讼或要求撤稿，而是打电话说他很失望。“深感失望，”这是他的原话。
"Any response," he sighed. And gently hung up the phone.
鹦鹉伸手去拿笔，希望能得到引文，这可能会引出第二篇文章。“这就是你要说的全部吗？”她问。
"Hello," the parrot said, "Hello."
“没有任何回应，”他叹了口气。轻轻挂断了电话。
The pig would not have admitted it, but what really bothered him was the pot-belly business. He'd been plump all through his youth, and the years of name calling had not just shaped his adult life but deformed it, like some cell made crazy by radiation.
“喂，”鹦鹉说，“喂。”
He couldn't remember the last time he'd eaten without thinking. Popped a passing canape into his mouth, finished an entire potato chip or dry roasted peanut without calculating the damage. While others prepared for bed, he ran a treadmill. They tucked into their ample breakfasts, and he hung upside down from a bar in his living room, doubling at the waist until he saw stars. Then came the traditional sit-ups, and a half a slice of dry Ry-Vita before examining his silhouette in the hallway mirror and getting ready for work.
这头猪不会承认，但真正困扰他的是“大肚”这件事。他在整个青年时期一直很丰满，多年的恶语相向不仅塑造了他的成年生活，还扭曲了它，就像某些被辐射导致畸变的细胞。
He did not have a pot-belly. He would never again have a pot-belly. But now, here was this article, essentially, comparing him to Buddha. After hanging up on the reporter, the pig began a three-day fast. Lunchtime came, and as his colleagues shuffled to the museum cafeteria, he sat at his desk and looked out the window at that stupid hawk, marching back and forth with his picket sign.
他不记得上一次不假思索地吃东西是什么时候了。把路过的小吃塞进嘴里，吃完一整片薯片或干烤花生而不计算后果。当别人准备睡觉时，他在跑跑步机。他们享用丰盛的早餐，而他在客厅的横杆上倒挂，在腰部折叠直到眼冒金星。然后是传统的仰卧起坐，以及半片干瑞沃饼，然后盯着走廊镜子里的轮廓，准备去工作。
The veteran had hoped that others might join him, but none of his fellows seemed to care. "The war is over, and it's time to move on," they'd been quoted as saying. "Who cares if some," and there was that word again, "Who cares if some pot-bellied Charlie wants to hang a picture on the wall?"
他没有大肚。他永远不会再有大肚。但现在，有了这篇文章，本质上是将他比作佛陀。挂断记者电话后，猪开始了为期三天的绝食。午餐时间到了，当同事们走到博物馆食堂时，他坐在办公桌前望着窗外那只蠢鹰，举着标语牌来回踱步。
"Damn that parrot from the Eagle." The pig's anger felt vaguely nourishing, but he knew that it was misplaced. The reporter hadn't assigned the animals their names. That was someone else's doing, someone who sat back and ordained, wide-mouth bass, humpback whale, lesser wart-nosed horseshoe bat, not caring whose life was ruined.
老兵希望别人能加入他，但他的同僚似乎都不在乎。“战争已经结束了，该向前看了，”他们被引用说。“谁在乎是不是有些，”又有了那个词，“谁在乎是不是有些大肚查理想要把画挂在墙上？”
By the time he next ran into her, the pig had lost close to 10 pounds. They met at a museum benefit, a costume ball which he hosted, and which she hovered on the edges of, guzzling rum punch and gathering quote she'd heard a 1,000 times before. "Wonderful party and, of course, it's for such a good cause."
“该死那只《鹰报》的鹦鹉。”猪的愤怒让他感到隐约的滋养，但他知道那是错位的。记者没给动物取名字。那是别人的作为，一个坐着下达旨意的人，阔嘴鲈鱼、座头鲸、小疣鼻蝠，不在乎谁的生活被毁了。
The parrot was, she liked to joke, back with the living, by which I mean section, not the sensation of being alive. She'd assumed that the pig would be in disguise, and was surprised to see him in the same dark suit he worn at the restaurant. He was standing at the bar, nursing a glass of water.
当他下次遇见她时，猪瘦了近10磅。他们在博物馆的慈善晚会上见面，一场他主持的化妆舞会，而她在边缘徘徊，猛喝朗姆潘趣酒并收集她听过一千遍的引言。“精彩的派对，当然，这是为了一个如此好的事业。”
And she came from behind and tapped him on the shoulder. "Let me guess," she said, "you're Henry Bacon, right?"
鹦鹉，她喜欢开玩笑说，回到了“生活”，我的意思是版块，而不是活着的感受。她本以为猪会伪装，看到他穿着在餐厅穿的那套深色西装很惊讶。他站在吧台边，喝着一杯水。
"Who's he?" the pig asked.
她从后面走过来拍了拍他的肩膀。“让我猜猜，”她说，“你是亨利·培根，对吧？”
The parrot rolled her eyes. "American architect, designed a little something called the Lincoln Memorial?"
“他是谁？”猪问。
"Oh," the the pig said, "that Henry Bacon." He was going to admit that he was no one or, at least, no one special, when the parrot stepped back and examined him again over the rim of her punch class.
鹦鹉翻了个白眼。“美国建筑师，设计了林肯纪念堂那个小玩意儿？”
"I've got it," she said, "you're Luther Ham, took the silver medal for 200 meter freestyle, Helsinki 1952. Little wisp of a thing, but, boy, did he have shoulders."
“噢，”猪说，“那个亨利·培根。”他正要承认自己什么都不是，或者至少不是什么特别的人，鹦鹉退后一步，在她的潘趣酒杯缘上方再次打量他。
"Right," the pig said. "So who are you supposed to be?"
“我有主意了，”她说，“你是卢瑟·哈姆，1952年赫尔辛基奥运会200米自由泳银牌得主。虽然瘦小，但天呐，他的肩膀。”
The parrot shrugged and held up her glass for a refill. "I thought I'd go all out and come as a two-bit journalist." For verification, she presented an ink stained claw. "So hey," she added, "I'm sorry about that article."
“对，”猪说。“那你应该是谁？”
"That's all right," the pig told her.
鹦鹉耸耸肩，举起杯子要求续杯。“我本想全情投入，扮成一个二流记者。”为了证明，她伸出了一只染了墨水的爪子。“所以嘿，”她补充道，“那篇文章我很抱歉。”
"All right for you," the parrot said, "I'm the one with the god damn hawk calling me every 10 minutes. Now he wants to go after Middle Easterners. Heard of a Persian cat who runs a parking garage down by the civic center and is after me to write an expose."
“没关系，”猪对她说。
The pig laughed for the first time in months, and immediately thereafter, as was his habit, he began to analyze why. Was it the idea of this parrot bedeviled by a ridiculous hawk, or the image of a long-haired cat making change in one of those sweltering little booths? He pondered this for days but never reached a satisfying conclusion.
“对你没关系，”鹦鹉说，“我才是那个被该死的鹰每10分钟打一次电话的人。现在他要去找中东人的茬。听说市中心停车场有个波斯猫馆长，正求着我写一篇揭秘报道。”
"Earth to pig, Earth to pig," the parrot said.
猪几个月来第一次笑了，紧接着，按照习惯，他开始分析原因。是因为这个被荒谬的鹰折磨的鹦鹉的想法，还是长毛猫在闷热小亭子里找零钱的画面？他思考了几天但从未得出令人满意的结论。
And he looked down to see her wing resting on his stomach.
“地球呼叫猪，地球呼叫猪，”鹦鹉说。
"Is it my imagination or have you lost some weight?"
他低头看到她的翅膀停在他的肚子上。
"No," he told her, "I mean, yes I did. It's not your imagination." He thought of how kind it was for her to mention it. And then he noticed how oddly satisfying it felt to be patted down by a wing.
“是我想象力丰富，还是你瘦了一些？”
Meanwhile, the parrot was still talking. "Don't get me wrong," she said, "I have seen a cockatoo in my time, but I'm not dating anyone now if that's what you're wondering." She grabbed a passing appetizer, dumped the caviar back onto the tray and ate only the cracker. "A cliche, I know, parrot eats a cracker, but fish eggs make me bloat."
“不，”他告诉她，“我是说，是的，我瘦了。这不是你的想象力。”他想到她提及这件事是多么善良。然后他注意到被翅膀拍打的感觉有多么奇妙地令人满足。
"It's the salt," the pig told her . He'd hoped to say something more interesting, but, just then, the band started up. A wolf, in sheep's clothing, called out for a foxtrot. And as if a switch had been thrown, the party came to life. Here was the hare in cat's pajamas dancing with a chameleon whose costume changed with every turn. The Ugly Duckling cut in on a swan. A trio of mice lowered their sunglasses, and as they scouted the floor for partners, the parrot turned to the pig and held out her claw.
与此同时，鹦鹉还在说话。“别误会，”她说，“我见过凤头鹦鹉，但我现在没和任何人约会，如果你想知道的话。”她抓了一个路过的开胃菜，把鱼子酱倒回托盘，只吃了饼干。“老套，我知道，鹦鹉吃饼干，但鱼卵让我胀气。”
He accepted it awkwardly in his hoof, this spindly pitchfork, this warm, mottled twig. And so began, what the reporter would later refer to, as her days of swine and roses.
“是盐，”猪告诉她。他希望说点更有趣的事，但就在这时，乐队开始了。一个披着羊皮的狼高喊着要跳狐步舞。就像一个开关被拨动，派对活跃起来。这是穿着猫睡衣的野兔在与每转一圈就变色的变色龙跳舞。丑小鸭切入天鹅的舞步。三只老鼠放下太阳镜，当它们在舞池寻找舞伴时，鹦鹉转向猪，伸出了她的爪子。
David Sedaris is the author of several books, most recently, Dress Your Family in Corduroy and Denim.
他笨拙地用蹄子接受了它，这根细长的干草叉，这根温暖、斑驳的小树枝。于是开始了，记者后来称之为，她“猪与玫瑰”的日子。
Our program was produced today by Diane Cook and myself with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Alix Spiegel, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Seth Lind, and Steven January. Special thanks today to Ben Resner and Irene Pepperberg.
大卫·塞达里斯是几本书的作者，最近的一本是《给家人穿上灯芯绒和牛仔布》。
Our web site, where you can listen to our programs for absolutely free, www.ThisAmericanLife.org, or you know you can download today's program in our archives at audible.com/ThisAmericanLife. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的节目今天由黛安·库克和我本人制作，还有亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格、简·费尔特斯、萨拉·柯尼格、丽莎·波拉克、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和南希·厄普代克。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。塞思·林德和史蒂文·一月提供了制作帮助。特别感谢本·雷斯纳和艾琳·佩珀伯格。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
我们的网站，您可以免费收听我们的节目，www.ThisAmericanLife.org，或者您可以从我们的存档中下载今天的节目，audible.com/ThisAmericanLife。《这就是美国生活》由公共广播国际公司分发。
WBEZ management oversight for our show by Mr. Torey Malatia, who says that he had a dream exactly like today's show, all three acts. The dream even included me reading these very credits.
[赞助商致谢]
"Yeah, that was a dream I had, and I remember that dream, and I remember thinking that, you know, I got to stop smoking pot, man."
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他说他做了一个和今天节目一模一样的梦，所有三个幕。这个梦甚至包括我在读这些制作人员名单。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
“是的，那是我做的梦，我记得那个梦，我记得当时心想，你知道，我得停止抽大麻，伙计。”
PRI Public Radio International
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《这就是美国生活》的故事回来。